bro bro bro bro jarick bro bro bro hey
bro what dinner party I know bro I can't
believe we got this invite did you see
the stationery it was on embossed
question what is that emboss is like
when they have no what is that that
you're wearing did you read the invite
that you think Frank is gonna be they
said the dress code was sexy casual what
about Mike really miss my like a high
school football dropout this is a formal
dinner party haven't seen Mike since we
all work together at the water bar Quinn
it was great about the water bar they
had the best lobster oh my god Mike is
dead formal well I'm on it I'm full sexy
casual right now you're wearing a
varsity jacket and a shirt that looks
like a dress from Eileen Fisher exactly
sexy casual this is a st. Laurent
varsity jacket also not paying rent this
button slash next month slash I'm not
showing up with you like this you can
hang back like you're my little brother
or something oh okay what just like just
like high school all over again like a
street drifter who happened to follow me
you thought you were so much cooler than
so my fault that the young Hemingway
Club basically ruled campus that is
hysterical because you actually think
you were cool I was totally trolling you
you you are dude I don't wanna get in a
flame war because you're pissed are
gonna have to go change but what about
you what are you wearing you're like
wearing a full-on tux
so I mean a tux is not casual it is when
it's my casual tux midnight blue we do
look pretty sick really salvia no I'm
not shopped cropped those dude let the
tagline to the reality series where you
sit and stare at your phone all day good
question there's a number of people who
follow you on and stuff in with a K this
week
Quinn spends two hours posing and then
finally takes a photo of his shoes uh
this week okay yes that did happen but
this week regardless of the haters Quinn
remains one of America's fastest rising
tastemakers this week Quinn gets by the
way I figured it out what your tux it's
good shells gonna be there what now dude
she broke up with you get over it was
mutual I was there it was not she just
needle up that table at the restaurant
your birthday party and get cake all
over you just please go change bro when
we get there Mike is totally gonna back
me up on my outfit and I was gonna have
some dope Margiela's and it's awesome
Rico and so Dee like he's oh my god I
just remembered Mike is still dead
hey guys thanks so much for watching
please subscribe to the dry